and so if somebody's listening and
they're like okay cool you made millions
how did you go to zero so what what what
was happening what how are you making
money and how are you taking it to zero
were you just making wild bets or Wow
yeah yeah but where you're like hit I
imagine you've had like three hits yeah
I would say it's more like five or six
hits again
for better or for worse I needed all
five or six but the first one again I
was working at HBO and I made their
website and at at the time other
entertainment companies and other
companies they didn't even know what
this internet web thing was this was in
1995 and companies like American Express
American and his world have an American
Express would call Arthur Anderson which
was their accounting firm and you know
Arthur Andersen famously went out of
business in a scandal six years later
but American Express called him Arthur
Andersen said can you make us a website
Arthur Anderson said sure well they're
gonna charge you millions of dollars
Arthur Andersen would then call another
software consulting company and they
would say yeah will charge you a million
dollars the software company would call
me because nobody knew how to make a
website in 1994-1995
so I would say sure I'll do it and then
suddenly they pay me and my
brother-in-law $250,000 to make American
Express calm so that was one of our
first websites and I were at HBO at the
time was 40,000 a year so my
brother-in-law and I we made HBO com
then we made websites for everything
from Warner Brothers Sony Disney BMG all
the record labels like we did every
gangster rap record label bad boy loud
records jive death row Interscope we did
the movies for the matrix and many other
movies but anyway that was and were
these built up sites at that time like
if you looked at that website today what
would it look like is it like a
Craigslist well you know what that's a
great question so no it doesn't look
like Craigslist I wish it did but design
Web Design back in those days so I was a
software guy my brother-in-law was a
design guy web design back in those days
was very heavy so there would be like
big heavy images and animations using
flash or
yeah you know some Mac I forget the
company macro something and they were
there are very heavy designs not that
usable and but yeah I mean they were
okay
there they were admired back then so the
website for the matrix was a great
website which you know on archive.org
you could find or HBO's web site was a
great website but it wasn't as
functional as all websites are now
wasn't very easy to navigate and you
walk away with at the end of that about
15 million and then oh yeah so cash
not not like so a lot of people then you
know when public or sold and they got
paper and then they died in the dot-com
bust because the paper went to zero the
stocks went to zero so I had enough
sense
I liked the peak in 1999 I cashed out
and I had the cash in my checking
account like I didn't even what do you
mean cash out were you getting like
stock in these company yeah so so no I
sold the company to a company that was
rolling up web agencies and so we in a
sense that was how we went public like
some company that made
I don't know vacuum cleaners or whatever
decided to get into the internet
business in 1998 and acquired us and so
suddenly they were an Internet company
and the stock went from three to forty
eight and I cashed out with literally at
the peak with about a little over 15
million almost 16 million cash and and
here I was I was smart every step of the
way like I knew that the web design
development business industry was going
away because they were teaching web you
know how to make a website in junior
high school classes so I knew that was
going away I was smart I sold the
business I cashed out as fast as I could
and then I became everybody you suddenly
when you when you make money at one
thing suddenly you think you're a genius
and everything or at least this happened
to me and everybody would come to me and
say hey how can what what should we
invest in or you know this internet
thing you you you have like curly hair
and glasses you must know how this all
this internet stuff you're you look like
a technology guy what should we invest
in so I started thinking oh I must be
really smart at this and literally I
poured all this cash back into
uh internet investments after I cashed
out of the Internet and it really went
and then I also I bought like a huge
apartment in New York City and the one
thing I was doing that everybody thought
I lost all my money on but it wasn't I
was I was gambling every single day like
I was playing poker for 365 straight
days I played poker at least eight to
ten hours a day I was really ask you if
you're a degenerate gambler because you
kind of have that I mean you sound like
that before you told me you're a gambler
but but but that's just it poker was the
one thing I probably should have stuck
with like I was doing well at poker and
it was right before poker boom took off
when I decided you know what I'm just
gonna focus on starting new companies
and internet investing and I stopped
playing poker like in you know right at
the end of 1999 I started a venture
capital firm and I just started
investing money and which was your firm
all your money so your firm no no we
raised we raised two hundred million
dollars like we that was the other
thing too I didn't have any experience
doing any of this stuff I didn't know
anything um I'm trying to remember all
investors uh see s first Boston Deutsche
Bank like all these major banks gave us
money and then another company invest
Corp which is a major private equity
firm gave us a hundred million and and
then I started investing my own personal
money side-by-side with the fund and in
other investments and I started buying
stocks all the way down so hello zero
from 15 is zero how long was that I was
losing about a million dollars a week in
the summer of 2000 and and I just didn't
know what I was doing and it wasn't even
that I didn't know how to invest I
didn't know there's so many other skills
to investing than knowing what companies
are good and what companies are bad like
I didn't understand risk I didn't
understand money management I didn't
understand you know how to I really
didn't understand anything that about
investing like I was an idiot and I went
to zero by right around mid 2001 I put
up my I was desperately putting up my
apartment for sale cuz maybe I would
have some money left
I stopped paying my mortgage and maybe I
would have some money left after putting
this apartment up for sale I lived two
blocks three blocks from a little
building called the World Trade Center
and we were getting an offer on
September 11 and of course many worse
things happened that day than me not
getting an offer for my house but 9/11
happened and we couldn't sell then
because we were part of the crime scene
and you know just I went totally were
you only broke were you home I was at
the World Trade Center oh my god which I
don't really I don't really talk about
because a it sounds unbelievable but be
it all so many worse things happen to
people too many more people than me that
day obviously but my business partner
and I were there was a Dean & Deluca and
on the first floor of the World Trade
Center we ate breakfast there every day
and then we would day trade the markets
and at that point I was starting to come
back a little bit from day trading and I
had written some software and and so on
and then we're walking to my home where
I had my office and we my partner turns
to me and says it's the president coming
into town today cuz this I look up and
there's this plane that's just like
right overhead and then BOOM we watched
it go right into that like physically we
watched it not on TV but like physically
we saw it go right into the building and
everybody on the street instinctively
ducked and and your brain does weird
things so my I started thinking to
myself like my business partners name's
Dan
he said we're we're being attacked and
I'm like no no no that was that was just
an accident like and no one's no one's
it's too early no one's in the building
like my brain was telling me this even
though it was a quarter to 9:00 a.m. and
you know how do you remote control us of
whatever was a 747 into the World Trade
Center but that's what my brain was
telling me so we run to the fire station
and we say we want to help and these
guys throw two firemen suits at us and
say get this on we're gonna go straight
over there and we start putting it on
but then they say wait a second are you
guys firemen and we're like no we just
wanted to give blood or whatever we
could
and they're like no no only firemen and
that fire station it was the Duane
Street fire station a hundred percent of
those people died who went to the World
Trade Center that morning and and then
from you know there's a bad day but that
kind of clinched me losing everything
also because I had been invested in the
stock market that morning and boom
everything kind of went to went to zero
after that and then I was just desperate
for like a year and a half couldn't sell
the place couldn't there were no jobs I
was an idiot nobody would I had no
friends anymore and you know I had to I
had to teach myself how to invest so I
wrote some software where I took every
piece of data about every single stock
since World War two and looked for
patterns you know when would I would
have my software fine statistically
significant patterns where trades were
good so I would try to model let's say
fear and greed in the markets and and
and it worked pretty well doesn't it
wouldn't I don't think that strategy
would work now but it worked then
because there weren't there wasn't that
many quantitative investors in the
markets then this was kind of the
beginnings of that and so I was very
successful with it and that kind of kept
me alive and that's how I bit by bit I
started learning about investing this
gave me time to actually learn the skill
and and talk to people who were experts
and professionals and and really learned
then I started writing about investing
and I started going on CNBC and I
started a hedge fund and I start I wrote
my first book about investing and so
gradually I built these two careers one
in the hedge fund business and the other
in writing about investing and going on
CNBC and then I built so I was doing
deals also then and making money and
then I built a website that combined my
interest in web development with
investing me like a social I called it
the myspace of Finance cuz myspace was
big then and I sold that site and that
was like my next big hit sold that for
ten million and
you know and then a year later I was
broke again and that's things like that
just kept happening
[Music]